Joining me via skype this week is Ayaan
Hirsi Ali.
I hope that most of you already know
ion,
but in case you don't,
her story is truly an incredible one
that takes her from a childhood in
Somalia to an elected member of
parliament in Holland to a fearless free
speech advocate,
a hated by both the extreme right and
the regressive left.
We'll dive deeper into her life's
incredible journey shortly,
but before we do that,
I wanted to take a moment to talk about
why people like Ian actually matter.
As our show has gained momentum here,
I realized that what we're doing is
really becoming an influential force for
the things that I believed that
mattered,
namely the battle of ideas,
free speech,
and liberal values.
At the end of the day,
though,
I want this to be about more than talk
because the repercussions of these ideas
that we're talking about aren't just
abstract notions.
There stark realities for so many
people.
I had Hirsi Ali as a survivor in every
sense of the word.
She survived.
Genital mutilation is a child.
She survived a forced marriage to a
cousin.
She survived the cold blooded murder of
a friend in broad daylight in Amsterdam
and subsequent death threats.
Many people would've given up after any
of these horrific events.
Many people would have just accepted
that this is what life has given them
and remain quiet.
Many people right this very second are
doing just that.
By the way,
I find no fault with these people who
remain silent under such subjugation.
They see no way out and sadly,
even though it's in the secular world
who want to help them fear the
repercussions if they speak out,
not ion though she has bravely and
boldly fought for women's rights,
brought the issue of female genital
mutilation out in the open and
relentlessly made her life story a cause
bigger than herself.
It's easy to sit back and privately talk
about these things or tweet about them
from the comfort of your own home,
but she's actually out there putting her
life on the line after they already
tried to take it from her.
I want to be very clear here that when I
talk about these issues,
I'm talking about ideas and not people.
This seems to be a major sticking point
in this conversation and I really hope
that we can eventually get past that,
not just for the health of the debate,
but for all the young people currently
being indoctrinated with this ideology.
Imagine if a political party had a
platform that included female genital
mutilation,
forced marriage and death for apostates.
Absolutely insane and ridiculous.
Right?
Well,
guess what?
Religious ideas,
cultural ideas,
any ideas deserve the exact same
scrutiny no matter how uncomfortable it
makes us.
I for one,
would rather live in a society that
deals with uncomfortable truths out in
the open,
then one that leaves huge portions of
people alone in the dark.
I'm here with Ion Hirsi Ali,
human rights activist and author of the
new book heretic.
Why Islam needs a reformation?
Now I am welcome to the show.
Thank you.
Thank you dave.
Thank you for having me on.
So I'm going to show all my cards right
upfront here.
I'm such a huge admirer of yours and I
think you've done such good work and,
and your story's amazing and your,
your bravery is amazing.
So I'm going to hold nothing back and
just set us off on that,
on that good welcoming note.
Is that okay with you?
Thank you.
Thank you for having me on again,
and we'll thank you for everything you
said.
So,
uh,
there's a ton that I want to talk to you
about and so many of the things that
your life is an example of are the
things that we've been talking about on
the show here for months now.
And I know many of my guests have been
people that you're friends with and,
and coworkers with and I've done
speeches with,
um,
but your story is the most unique and
most interesting.
And I want to talk about the book,
but I thought we could just spend about
10 minutes just sort of on your
biography and I know you've,
you've discussed it a lot and that's one
of the books is about,
but if you could,
it's so illuminating to sort of how you
got here.
So if you could just tell me a little
bit first about growing up in Somalia
and uh,
let's just start with that.
Well,
I was born into a Somali Muslim
household and if I look at my journey
from,
I was born in 19,
69 November,
my family went to Saudi Arabia,
we lived in Ethiopia,
we lived in Kenya,
and then I went to the Netherlands and
now I live in the United States of
America.
I think if you look at my geographical
journey,
there's really nothing unique about it
today.
People from all over the world moved to
different places,
learn different languages and adapt to
different situations.
I think that what Western is a find
interesting,
intriguing,
and maybe in some ways disconcerting is
the intellectual journey.
Uh,
I was raised as a Muslim.
I was raised in a clan or tribal society
and the model framework that prevails
there is that of honor and shame and
it's a different kind of honor and shame
from what we believe here in the West,
which is,
you know,
as a little girl at the age of five,
my genitals were cut and when I was old
enough to ask why did that happen?
My grandmother was very,
you know,
she really explained it as well.
We purified you and if you are not
purified,
you will never find a husband.
So that kind of practice is,
and it isn't something that happened
only to me.
It happened to happens according to the
United Nations number is two 98 percent
of Somalis,
Egyptians,
Sudanese.
Uh,
so that's one thing that people find
fascinating.
How could you have India with something
like that and come out a cultural
context like that.
And then fast forward,
when I'm 22 years old,
my father returns from a long journey.
He was,
he had left at this for 10 years in
Kenya,
a country that if you're a Somali,
you feel you know,
you are in a foreign country,
comes back and he feels he has the show
as my father to marry me off until the
first student,
the first guy who comes along and says,
you know,
I'm off the same clan as you.
I'm looking for a wife,
which go would you like to offer?
And then I'm the one who offered.
So to Western as that seems pretty
straight,
this person,
just to be clear that this person was a
distant cousin of yours,
right?
Which probably wasn't that abnormal for,
for that area.
Absolutely not.
In fact,
the closer the kinship,
the better because the only way to make
sure that family members are loyal to
one another.
Share wealth,
don't mistreat one another,
is to try and marry within the same
family as much as possible.
Obviously with all the genetical
problems,
but that's not what we were looking at.
But that's it.
That's the context.
You know,
your,
your roles as a male,
as a female that's given as a female you
can bring shame not only on your father
and mother,
your brother and sister,
but the extended family as well.
And even extended religion.
And so I think what is fascinating for
most Western as is how could you that
intellectual journey.
How come?
Once I believed in all of that,
I lived it and now I,
I'm saying,
you know,
as an individual you have a right to be
free,
to choose who you want to marry.
You don't have to cut off the genitals
of girls for them to be married.
You don't even have to be mad if you
don't want to,
because as an economic security,
as a woman in the western context where
there is the rule of law,
what is freedom and where there's this
wonderful education systems.
I was a go.
You can actually choose what you want to
do in life.
You can map out your own destiny.
Yeah,
and that's,
that's why I love your story so much and
why I find you so inspirational because
you're,
you're truly living,
breathing proof that things can change
and that people and girls,
especially from this part of the world
can have a different life.
And that's why I find it so wonderful.
But let's just back up for just a
second.
On the female genital mutilation.
When,
when this happened to you,
um,
did you immediately,
and you spoke to your grandmother and
all this,
but did you immediately questioned
everything I to be that age and go
through something like that?
How long,
how long did it take before you really
were questioning everything about your
life?
At the age of five,
I didn't question it at the age of 10,
I didn't question anything at the age of
20,
but I didn't question anything.
But there's always,
as you grow up,
and I remember for me,
um,
in,
in terms of evolving as you're evolving
from childhood to maturity,
it was the ages of 14,
15,
16 when I want to know,
you know,
what's the point of this life and why
are we put on rf and is it only to
reproduce?
We're at that point in my family,
I,
we're going through a lot of adversity
and it is what is the point,
what is the point?
So instead of being suicidal,
I joined the Muslim Brotherhood because
they make the point so very clear.
You've been put on this earth to be by
God to be tested for your absolute
submission.
You're going to be tested as a female in
various ways and as a male in various
ways.
And you just have to say yes to that
submits and on your points and for your
audience.
I'm just going to give you one
interesting,
um,
way in which,
how do they,
how,
how does one even manipulate that as a
believing Muslim?
How does one know that you know you're
doing what God wants you to do?
You have two angels on either side of
your shoulders.
When you're hide side,
you have an angel that notes down minute
by minute,
second by second you have good
intentions versus you have bad
intentions.
So we're not here.
We're not even talking about what you
say before you say it,
but on top of that,
that same angel also notes Don what you
say,
and then your behavior and on your left,
same thing.
Everything that you do that is strong,
that angel is doing the book keeping and
you will live,
and at some point you die.
And then there is the here after this,
the Day of Judgment.
And we're told as Muslims,
no one can escape that you're,
oh God.
And His tribe,
you know,
you'll be for God and his tribe.
You know the prophets,
the angels of all his other human
beings.
And those two books are going to be put
on a scale and if you afraid handbook
weighs heavier than your left hand book,
you go to heaven and if you are left,
handbook goes weighs heavier,
you go to hell.
And you know as you grow up,
it's especially with the radical
Islamisation of or things.
These things are made so explicit to you
and you become so aware of them.
It's like in the west,
it's like taking,
keeping track of your calories.
Well,
it's interesting because even the way
you're describing it,
there's sort of a whimsical miss to the
way you're describing it because now as
a secular person,
it sounds so ridiculous to you.
And yet there's literally millions of
people that believe in this in a,
in a literal sense.
Absolutely,
absolutely.
And you know,
you're young,
you trust your parents,
your teachers,
your and Islam is your religion and
religion.
I mean,
I know that all human beings who are
religious are taught that the criteria,
you know,
the framework,
what,
how do we know the difference between
what's right and what's wrong?
Religion tells us that.
And so as a Muslim and Islam is a way of
life,
you are told that this is the difference
between right and wrong and these things
are spelled out that which is forbidden
her on that which is permitted.
Hello.
And so then it's up to you.
There's a level of,
there's a level of choice in there,
you know,
it sounds like,
it sounds like the guy on your shoulder
already knows your intentions anyway.
Right?
Exactly.
So even if you abstain,
they still.
Angel's still knows you want to indulge.
Wow.
Alright.
So I want to talk a lot about.
I want to talk.
It's funny that it seems funny to you
now.
I'm,
I'm glad to see that.
And you have a beautiful smile so it's
nice because you've,
you've come out of this.
So it really is nice.
So I just want to do one more thing on
your bio and then we can,
we can get into some of the specifics
about the doctrine and things sort of in
your life after that.
Um,
so you,
you made political asylum in the
Netherlands,
you then became member of parliament.
This is an incredible story of success
and you know,
with all the refugee things going on in
Europe right now,
there's a lot of parallels to that.
You found safety and became successful
and influential and went on to talk
about female genital mutilation and
women's rights and all this incredible
stuff.
But here,
of course I have to mention that then
Theo van Gogh was doing a movie based on
a script that you wrote and he was
killed by a Muslim extremist in broad
daylight in Amsterdam at 9:00
AM in the morning.
And as if that wasn't horrific enough,
the person that killed him pinned a
death threat to you on this person's
body.
Now I know,
I know you've talked about this a lot
and I know people hear things like this
and I don't think he quite gets to them.
You know,
it sounds like a movie sort of.
Right?
And so I just want you to talk about a
little bit about it specifically,
but also just the feeling that it left
you with the sort of terror.
Because it's one thing to say these
things happen,
but you're,
you're a person that these things
actually happen to.
Well,
in a way I have to say the difference
between a Theo fungo and myself was that
I believed in those threats.
I didn't know exactly what the
individuals who were threatening me
would do.
So two years prior to a theo's death,
I started to take all kinds of security
precautions and when he and I were
working together,
I kept saying to you,
you know,
I know it sounds surreal in a Dutch
context.
I think he would tell me over and over
again,
do you know the last thing in the
Netherlands,
someone was killed because of what they
believed in,
and he would give me years from the 17th
century like we,
we had Dutch,
this is the Netherlands,
we don't do that sort of thing,
so relaxed,
let's do this.
And that was actually true because.
Because Holland was an incredible place
of mixed cultures and religions and
ethnicities and all that.
Right?
Absolutely.
And it wasn't only that,
it was also in the wider Europe when in
hundreds of years ago to a 17th century,
18th century,
when on religious grounds people would
face in tolerance,
so much as to threaten their lives,
thinkers,
creative people.
They would go to the Netherlands and
they would get a sanctuary.
And so for him it was for Theo,
it making this film,
it wasn't about that,
it was about preserving what he knew was
his culture,
his civilization,
and really not just Dutch civilization.
I think civilization with a capital c
when human beings can discuss and,
uh,
can disagree without having to threaten
with force,
right?
So in a bizarre way by,
by them killing him instead of you in a,
in a weird,
I know this sounds perverse or
something,
but that was more of a direct attack on
Holland,
right?
Because they were going after one of
their own,
so to speak,
so to speak.
And I had,
I had accepted the perimeters that the
government puts me within,
you know,
a security framework,
which was a really is something that I
would never ever accept anything like
that because these security measures a
cattail,
you have freedom to a degree that you
are not free.
And Him I'm never going to accept that.
And he wanted to prove to them it is not
having to put a shell around the people
who are practicing free speech.
That is not the answer.
The answer is to openly discuss these
things and make them open.
If these people are provoked by what is
that was that particular film was this
is what the Koran says about women.
This is how it's put into practice.
That's what we need to be talking about.
Why we shouldn't be talking about
security.
And he gets killed.
And I think by doing the murderer killed
Theo fungo and that incident confronted
Dutch society and Dutch leadership.
And I think the wider European Western
leadership with,
you know,
we can all go around saying,
talking about the First Amendment,
freedom of speech,
freedom of expression,
all of this.
That.
And the other,
but what are we willing to do to
preserve it?
And he,
he has left us with that question and
I'm disappointed to say that so far we
haven't done that much because as you
know,
this year,
the beginning of this year,
the cartoonists in Paris or killed and
the threats to free speech continues and
if government policies are anything to
go by,
it seems as if they are telling us it's
best not to provoke them.
Yeah.
All right.
So I really want to focus on that
because that's been one of,
you know,
this free speech,
uh,
and political correctness.
It's become this perfect storm that's
actually strengthening everything that
it should be against a.
But just to put a final cap on your bio
and all that.
What was it like for you?
I mean really at the,
at the personal level,
when,
when he was killed,
did you want to just disappeared?
Did you want to leave the country?
Did you want to give up?
Because now you've lived for these last.
How many years ago was this?
This was
this for,
right?
So you've lived for these last 11 years
honoring everything he stood for,
but I'm sure there must have been a time
when you thought,
let me just get out of this.
Right?
Well,
I think it every day.
I think it all the time.
It's so tempting to just think,
you know,
I've done enough.
I'm,
I'm.
This is my age.
I'm 46 years old next month.
Uh,
there's nothing for me in it personally,
but it's,
I think it's what high accident made the
difference between being comfortable,
which if I just disappeared and changed
my name,
I would be very comfortable versus
actually living,
which is when you're challenged and when
civilization is challenged,
when our freedoms are challenged,
we always rely on those who stand up for
it and those who wanted to push their
agenda through intimidation,
through force.
They know that their argument is very
weak.
Otherwise,
why would they avoid discussion?
Why is it difficult for them to showcase
what the Quran and Allah and Heidi's the
sayings of the Prophet Mohammed and the
Jewish food ins and the practice of
Islam says about women in essays to
women.
Why are they afraid of women?
All women had a 100 percent the freedom
to choose.
And if your message is superior,
why not?
Why not allow people to just choose for
it?
One of the things we've really focused
on here is what I'm now calling and what
Majid new eyes has coined as the
regressive left.
That there,
there are people I come from the
progressive world,
that that's where I've been for these
last couple of years and it's only
really in the last six months that I've
had my own awakening that I realized it
was my guys.
It's my guys on the left that are trying
to silence people like you in silence.
People like Sam Harris and,
and modular and all of this.
And uh,
and I've had salmon.
I've had my jacket on and I include you
in that.
Um,
and I think partially I think that Sam
said that party or my agent said the
part of his awakening was after a debate
that he had with you.
Um,
what do you make of this coming from the
left?
Because the left is supposed to debate
ideas,
right?
We're supposed to be about ideas free
thought and yet it's those very people
who are trying to silence you.
I,
I'm amazed by this.
I think what I've seen and I could be
wrong,
is that what the left does is they put
all the emphasis on justice,
the concept of justice and maybe what
the rights rather classical liberals
because those are the people I identify
with and in the US,
they are called conservatives,
sometimes libertarians.
But um,
what classical liberals do is they put
the emphasis on freedom.
And I was exposed to these concepts
between say 1995 when I go to the
University of flight and until 2000 and
then 2001 something happens that makes
me intent on testing these ideas.
And what I have discovered like many
people before me,
and I think you will as as you grow,
is that there is no justice without
freedom.
And so if you accept and that is freedom
from coercion,
freedom from being forced into doing
something you don't want to do or using
the tools of state to make individuals
to do something they don't want to do.
Or with government failing art,
you know,
having one individual take the freedom
of the other individuals.
But if you have no freedom then you will
have no adjustments.
Yeah.
So,
so I'm with you on just to see
secondary.
Right?
So what do you make of the tactics that
they use because there's been so much.
We've talked about it so much,
but so much lying and smearing about
people's views including your own.
Even when I,
when I've just tweeted that I'm having
you on the show.
Fortunately because we've built
something good here.
I think,
you know,
80 percent of it was positive,
but a lot of people she's racist.
I mean they're telling me that you are
racist.
So what,
what do you make of the tactics that
they're using?
Because I do think they think they're
doing something lofty.
They think they're there helping the
downtrodden or something like that when
in actuality they're strengthening the
very people that they should by
definition be against
and I think that is because if you put
the emphasis on justice,
you are by definition going to start
talking about groups and collectives.
Groups in abstract.
You belong to a group for a short period
of time.
You're a member of whatever you are,
collective you are a member of for a
certain amount of time but freely all
the time.
You are an individual.
So the basic arguments I used to have
with the left and I started out in the
Netherlands was okay,
so you want to protect the culture and
the religion of this collective and this
collective is saying,
if we don't practice our religion the
way we used to back at home,
we are just not happy.
We feel deprived when we feel
persecuted,
we don't feel at home and that has all
kinds of psychological effect on the
entire group.
But what about the individual?
What about the individual goal?
Who's removed from school?
What about individual girl who's forced
into a marriage where she's consistently
rate,
she can't reach out to her parents
because they put her in that situation.
Her husband thinks he has a right.
What about that individual?
Right.
What about the individual right to say,
I don't want to do this.
I want to do something else and you're
forcing this individual into doing that
and these constitutions in liberal
countries is all about heck.
Organizing that individual freedom and
aspiring to protect it as much as
possible,
and so what I tell my left wing friends
and I have a lot of them because a lot
of them have good intentions and they're
progressive and they want to stand up
for the poor.
The downtown.
It doesn't feel the same way.
Yeah,
it is.
Just to take them back to that unit so
that they can empathize with.
If you're gay and you're on the left and
on the one hand you belong to a
movement.
You're fighting for the right in America
to marry,
but on the other hand,
you're also fighting for the rights of
some minority collective to do what ever
they want.
To the individual members,
shouldn't you be thinking about the
plight of the individual members,
those who can't voice their wishes and
those who if they do have to deal with
consequences,
so die,
and I'm not talking about death and
threats,
I'm talking about your father looking
you in the eye and tell him you're no
longer my daughter.
I disown you.
You control yourself up in the mosque
you are not invited to,
so you are shunned.
And think of the psychological impact of
that on the individual who chooses to
have a lifestyle that is not in sync
with seventh century lifestyle.
Right?
And that lifestyle,
whether they're gay or a or just a
woman,
is what is what the progressive should
always be fighting for.
And that's the ultimate irony in this.
The ultimate irony,
these women that I.
I mean this is my background.
I wanted to be free to determine my own
destiny.
I didn't want to marry the man.
I was first in to Mary.
I wanted to find my own mate in life.
I wanted to work and I wanted to finish
my education and I was still.
That's going to bring shame on us.
Now with the emphasis on us,
that is the group,
the collective,
so it's always you,
the individual,
the unit,
and you're constantly being told you're
so selfish.
You're bringing down the whole family,
the whole clan,
the whole group and a in.
And here's the irony.
I think it used to be the left that
would take up the defense of the weak
and now unfortunately we live in a time
when it is the left that has decided to
define week units as groups,
not individuals.
So,
so what can we do?
So what can we do?
People,
people in the public sphere with a voice
that care about people on the left.
They're not even people I left that care
about liberal values.
What can we do?
Because when I see the tactics and the
way they treat you guys,
I even,
I've asked this to Sam and Majid,
I said,
you know,
there must be this piece of you that
wants to get out and that's why I asked
you to.
And I partly think that the reason that
they do it is they want to do enough
damage to you guys and people like you
so that everyone else.
It's not about you.
You know what I mean?
Like they'll get rid of you.
You'll just say,
okay,
I can't do this anymore and that.
But it's the chilling effect for
everyone beneath you.
So how,
how do we fight this?
It's above the utopia.
I think what we have to do is we have to
expose the fact that they are after a
utopia,
this whole justice thing,
the,
you know,
life would be wonderful if we had to.
Sharia law,
all of us.
It's just uncovered their message really
would we?
And I think if you are a liberal,
you have to revisit the basic principles
of liberalism.
And it was about individuals.
That is how the aristocracy was put in
its place back then when there was,
you know,
I have all of these rights because I
happened to belong to this family and
you're all surfs and you serve as,
as aristocrats because you happen to
belong to that collective.
It wasn't about that.
It is about individual freedom when it
was about,
you know,
fighting slavery,
you have to recognize the other person
who was the slave as a fellow human
being and as an individual fighting for
women's rights.
You had to recognize women as fellow
individual human rights in human beings
and the whole concept of human rights is
based on the individual and the freedom
of the individual and we know that we
are social animals and are social
animals and as individuals within our
families and within our communities,
within our workplace,
we have to negotiate that sweet spot,
that space where you can say,
I can be me and and this is how I can
serve my community and this is how my
community can serve me,
but all of that is not going to work if
individual liberty is compromised and
unfortunately the people who have
inherited these systems,
America,
Europeans are the free countries.
They're compromising that because they
think it's so.
There's this collective collective and
this story,
that narrative.
It is.
Think it's.
They think it's a lofty goal somehow,
but I do.
I do.
Do you sense that the tide is turning?
I feel like,
you know,
the social justice warrior thing and
this whole movement,
I feel like it's been gaining strength
for the last five years,
but I do think partly because of Charlie
Hebdo and sort of the general absurdity
of so much of it online and you know,
Brandeis University saying that they're
not going to give you an honorary
doctorate.
I mean the,
the height of absurdity to not give you
an honorary doctorate after they said
they would do it.
That I do sense that the tide is
turning.
I.
Am I just being optimistic there or do
you feel that?
I think what we're seeing is more and
more confrontations that really
pronounce this,
this struggle and I think one of them is
Israel versus the Arab Muslim world.
Uh,
he,
he is a liberal country.
It's a democracy for goodness sake.
And,
and we find a outside is telling them
what they can and can't do.
Who Do you know in the United States of
America,
if we had people throwing rocks at us,
knifing us.
If you had the leadership of the
opposition saying,
you know,
take a knife,
take a car,
take whatever weapon you can go after
them,
we would find it completely and deal
with it appropriately.
But when Israel desert,
we demonized and vilified Israel.
So in a weird way,
that's one way,
but that's one example.
Yeah.
And then we have more examples and
you've mentioned magic and myself and
all the other,
uh,
what I,
I don't know what is the right time to
use Muslim reformers,
Muslim modifiers,
Muslim heritage.
I think that is the right word.
Heretic is you're on the inside,
you start to ask questions and then
you'll fight and shunned by this group
because they don't want to change or
because they have an agenda for Sharia
and the Caliphate and Jihad and you
stand up to that and then they'd go
after you.
So we're seeing so many of these
confrontations in so many different
levels.
And I think the mistake is that you
know,
if,
if you're a socialist in the United
States,
think you know you're a Bernie Sanders
and you're hiding for president and you
are Donald Trump and you're running for
president,
you can say the most ridiculous things
in the world.
Nobody's going to kill him and nobody
expects you to be killed.
And if you are attacked,
if any violence against these two right
now,
these two extremes,
the American population is going to meet
that with such rejection and it's going
to be reviled and we have to teach the
rest of the world that it is possible to
disagree and to disagree radically,
but not use violence.
Less violence is used.
That's an interesting thought because we
always think or I think that our system
is so broken here.
Our political system is so broken and we
can't get things done properly in our
discourse is so silly and cable news,
but actually the way you just said that,
that look,
you have these two people who were,
couldn't be further from each other.
Trump and sanders,
the ultimate capitalist,
the ultimate socialist,
and yet they're not.
There is no threat.
There's no credible threat to their
lives.
Right?
So that does show that we have something
pretty good about our,
our Western society.
I know it's not cool to say that,
but that's the truth,
right?
That's the truth.
And it's,
it goes even more than that.
We also expect them to shake hands on
stage.
We expect them to be civil to one
another and they can disagree as much as
they like,
but you know why he is the general
public,
uh,
say the establishment Republicans.
Why are they angry with Donald trump?
I don't think it's because of his ideas.
Sometimes just because of the way he
speaks.
That goes a little tool five gets too
close to,
you know,
uncivilized behavior,
violent behavior.
Let's not do that.
There is,
is a culture here where,
yes,
people are violent.
There's a lot of,
there are a lot of guns out there and
people use these guns,
but mainstream Americans expect
mainstream Americans to behave in a
certain way.
And it's not a culture that says,
let's not disagree.
We know we all disagree.
Say the system is broken or it's the
human being that's fragile.
We disagree.
What we have is a system where you can
have these disagreements and these and
you can change your mind or you can go
as radical as you please,
but you are not expected to use violence
and the government is there to protect
you and with people putting question
marks on the first amendment.
The two different things is one part of
it is you know,
we can disagree with one another as much
as we like,
but there's a system here.
There's an infrastructure that allows us
to disagree with one another without the
use of violence.
If you start putting question marks on
the first amendment,
in other words,
you know,
defamation laws,
there are some religions or there are
some icons that you may or may not
criticize.
Then you are really eroding the system.
You're bringing down the system and this
system is superior to any other system
I've ever seen any other system in
history.
So our job is,
and here's where people like you and me
and Sam and magic seeing it's.
We've got to be careful that the
government does not enact lows where
some ideas cannot be criticized and
religion is just an idea.
It may be to you and everything,
but to me it's just an idea and all
ideas can be criticized.
It makes your idea on the stronger,
but we're not.
Yeah,
we must not challenge the.
Doesn't erode the system that makes that
possible,
so I'm.
I'm a first amendment fundamentalist if
you want.
If you're going to be a fundamentalist
of some kind,
I suppose that that's the one to be so I
know a lot of people will,
as I said earlier,
they'll call you and Islamophobia.
They'll tell Majid who's Muslim and
Islamophobia.
What do you make of the meme of
Islamophobia?
Because at one time I feared that the
government was going to come for our
free speech,
so infringing on our First Amendment.
Bottom.
Now fearing is that we're taking it away
from ourselves by what the universities
are doing and by every debate ends in
someone being called a racist.
Right?
We know what's happened to Sam that were
due.
It's not the government,
but it's the use of words to stifle
debate.
We're doing it ourselves.
You know?
Uh,
when the Charlie Hebdo incident
happened,
I expected all newspapers in the free
world,
all televisions,
the whole media,
to stand in solidarity with them and
republish those cartoons to show them
this is what we do.
This is what we are about.
It's an idea.
And the Islamophobia meme,
if you want to,
first of all,
you know,
to,
to criticize an idea is not to be
phobic.
Islam is a religion.
It's a faith.
It's a set of beliefs.
It's an idea.
It's not the people.
Muslims are very diverse and many of
them disagree on many things,
including the position of Muhammad,
including whether Marvin should be drawn
or not drawn,
criticized,
not criticized.
So given all of that,
yes,
you're right.
It's not only the government,
we shouldn't,
of course the government is lobbied by
57 member nations of the Organization of
Islamic Conference that through the
United Nations and other international
bodies is trying to make them adopt laws
that leave Islam out of that realm and
discussing ideas and criticizing ideas.
But it's not only that we're doing it to
ourselves,
schools are doing it,
the education system,
um,
the press,
even individually,
I think that some of it is because we
are scared because we think,
you know,
we don't want it to be,
we don't want to be short,
we don't want to be killed,
which is just what they want,
right?
They want the.
Because the fear is as powerful,
if not more powerful perhaps than,
than murdering somebody.
Right?
Absolutely.
That's the whole point of terrorism is
to.
They want to get what they want.
So this is.
So I would like to promote the idea that
men and women are equal and should be
equal before the law.
I want to get into every Muslim
community and promote that idea and I
know it's an uphill battle,
but for me to do that,
my life is not safe enough for the
Islamic extremists.
They wanted to promote the idea among
Muslim American citizens and others that
women and men should behave in a certain
way.
They can take advantage of all the
freedoms that we have,
freedom of religion,
of association of expression.
And I give them that,
why can't I do the same,
why is my government not protecting me
to promote my message,
which is 100 percent aligned with our
constitution.
Yeah.
It's so fascinating because it's so many
levels of,
of craziness.
I,
I suppose.
Um,
so I think part of the issue also is
that people get a little lost in the,
in the definition of terms.
Um,
so could you explain the difference
between the doctrine of Islam?
So sort of the religious side of it
versus what political Islam is.
Because I think that that split in
itself I think has many people very
confused.
And that's why I'm trying to use this
show to get people just to understand
the basic tenants of all this stuff
because maybe that will remove a bit of
where everyone says this is about
bigotry and racism and things like that.
Okay.
So in the seventh century,
a man called Mohammed comes with a
message.
So man,
Mohammed the message,
submit to one God,
forget about all your other got submits
to a,
my God,
the one who spoke to me and they're in
that cave called a hero and a bunch of
people say this mighty is crazy,
what are going to abandon our gods?
And he carries on.
So for the first 10 years,
what he is preaching is my God requires
you to pray too fast to look after the
poor,
to be charitable.
A lot of the things he was saying in
those fast 10 years would fall under
what you and I and a lot of Americans
and Europeans understand as religion.
You believe in these things and maybe
something good will happen.
Maybe something good,
you know you can mobilize.
If you look after the orphans,
I mean what's wrong with that?
That's great,
right?
And then the next 10 years of his life,
he moves from Mecca to a place called
Medina and he starts to put together a
militia and he starts to wage war.
Small wars that he wins that get bigger
and he starts to concrete and concrete.
Of course,
all that goes to his head and from then
on the second 10 years of Mohammed's
life,
that's when political Islam comes about.
On the first 10 years he was saying,
please reconsider.
Think about having all these many,
many gods.
Give them a come to my one.
Gordon would be your choice to do it
from Medina onwards.
You had to do it had to happen at the
tip of a sword and every victory
strengthened him and his followers in
doing that and that happened for
centuries afterwards.
So a lot of the people today who are
using Islam as a political tool to get
people to do what they want them to do.
A following Muhammad in this example.
That is.
That is why Mohammed is relevant.
That's why he needs to be discussed to
be drawn.
Who was he?
Did he really live?
Is this really what he said?
If he said so,
was it really more moral?
We should discuss Mohammed the way we
discuss Hannibal,
Julius Caesar,
you know this will water is of the past.
They Alexander the Great.
They established all these empires and
then now the historical figures.
That's how and it can we,
can we do that in 21st century America
without having our own demand around me
all the time without fearing for our
lives.
Unfortunately,
I know that the answer is to that,
and by the way,
a lot of people on the left,
liberals,
well intentioned,
wonderful,
wealthy liberals think that the way that
they can make Muslims as a minority feel
at home in America is by respecting the
icon and I think the best respect that
they can pay to the icon is to put him
along with all those other icons of the
past.
Isn't that what Bill Maher refers to
that as the soft bigotry of low
expectations that somehow we have to
treat these people differently.
I want,
you know,
I want everyone to be treated as Shitty
as everyone else.
It's about treating them well.
Treat everyone equally crappy that will
be good for me
and,
and bail my,
his,
you know,
his own clients.
He is one of those few liberals who is
saying,
I'm not going to make an exception for
my fellow American sentiment.
Why would I?
I want them to be.
I see them as equals and he knows there
are a lot of Muslim Americans laugh at
his jokes and who love him,
but they have to hide that from the
Islamic extremists inside of their
families and their communities.
So that's.
Yeah.
And it's our job to emancipate them by
saying I'm,
I,
I'm not in Pakistan or Afghanistan or
Somali or Egypt.
I'm now in America probably in La and I
want to laugh at my luck.
His jokes.
Yeah.
That's the crazy part,
right?
That Bill Maher when it comes to this
discussion,
is really being treated like a pariah by
the regressive left and they're calling
him.
And Sam,
of course racist because of that whole
Ben Affleck thing.
But we've spent so much time on that.
I don't want to get into that
specifically,
but,
but look what they've done to build.
I want to say why,
why doesn't Ben Afleck play the parts of
Mohammed the grade or something like
that.
That would be something,
right?
He had no problem playing a fallen angel
in dogma,
which was all about Christianity.
But I guess it's a little different in
this case.
Um,
so,
uh,
one of the,
one of the other things when I tweeted
about you was that a couple people said,
how could you have her on?
She's a neo-con that the urine neo-con
are you neo-con ion.
What if,
if somebody explained to me was an near
Connie's,
I might decide to be any record or not.
All right?
So I think,
I think what people are saying is that
the neocons,
they really think of the neocons as the
sort of George Bush,
Donald Rumsfeld,
Dick Cheney nation builders.
This idea that America can exert its
influence to nation build.
And I think they,
they lump you in on that.
Um,
take it away.
It's a position in felt foreign policy
that if you are going to intervene and
uh,
and you remember right after 9:11,
you know,
if we go out to,
as the United States of America,
we know we've been attacked from
Afghanistan.
We get into the affairs of that country.
How do we leave it now?
There were people who were saying,
we don't just go in and destroy and get
the bad guys and get out because we
leave the situation far worse than we
found it.
We have a responsibility to rebuild and
it's going to cost us a lot of blood and
treasure.
If those are the neocons,
count me in on them.
The fact that such a thing is really
quite murky and it takes a long time,
but I find that position to be more
noble than the position we are in now,
where we're going to go and get rid of
the feet and degrade and defeat isis by
bringing together people who really have
never fought and have them be defeated
and offer some airpower and just mock it
up and muddle through.
When the neocons were in charge.
If that is president George W Bush,
he did make huge mistakes early on,
but after the surge in Iraq was under
control and the rats lived in relative
fees,
we didn't have to pull out.
These are political positions and this
is policy and you can say,
what do you like about the marriage of
the policy?
But I think it is wrong to put labels on
their foreheads,
of people as neocons and this and that.
It's not.
There are a bunch of people who thought
about what would happen after you leave
the place.
Uh,
and,
and again,
I still think it's more responsible once
you invade a place to stay there until
things are in order instead of pulling
out two,
three years into it.
Right.
And I guess that's the irony is that,
you know,
we know in retrospect that the Iraq war
was based on faulty logic,
but when,
when we were there,
it was better than it is now.
And that's just a sad reality and that
doesn't mean we should be there forever.
But,
you know,
we look at the United States,
we're in this weird thing,
we do things,
people hate us,
we don't do things and look what's
happening now.
Yeah.
So I guess that gets you right.
They hate us anyway.
And I guess that gets your point about
labels.
I'm so sorry.
It's also about policies.
If you're in,
and maybe I can't blame it for people
who haven't been,
you know,
in parliamentary,
in poly,
whoever want to involved in policy,
every single policy has consequences,
intended consequences,
unintended consequences,
you name it.
So it's all about the positions you take
around these policy issues in the
position you take around a policy issue
should not define who you are and I
think people who then start coming up
with these names of neo-con this and
take it from the policy to the person
they are from their militias and the
acting in bad faith.
Yeah,
and the part of that that particularly
bothers me is that they think if they
can label you with that or whatever that
label is,
that then they can extrapolate every
other idea that you think and they think
they understand every other decision
that you make,
which you so rarely the case.
Many of us believe in many conflicting
things or have liberal values and
libertarian values and so on
that plus they also distract the
weaknesses of their policy position.
So it's all about not having to discuss
the merits and demerits.
I don't care if my opponent's position,
so I discussed the letter and I know
that they'll have weaknesses and they'll
have strengths,
but in order to discuss the policy
position to polish the proposal of the
other person,
I would never call him this or that.
It has to be about the policy.
Yeah.
Well it'd be your,
your,
what I would refer to as a true liberal
and willing to debate the ideas.
So I know we only have about 10 minutes
left and I wanted to discuss one thing
with you because I saw you.
I was probably about six months ago now
on the daily show when Jon Stewart was
still there and I interned at the daily
show in 1999.
John is,
you know,
we've met a couple of times and he's
given me some great advice about comedy
and life and I love John just like
everyone else loves John.
That said,
I thought his interview with you was
really terrible.
I thought every time you brought up
something about Islam again,
coming from the history that you come
from,
from your life,
your firsthand experience.
Every time you said something,
he immediately brought it back to
Christianity.
He immediately said,
well,
Christianity did this stuff and you're
focusing on Islam and I,
and it really was that regressive thing
that we started this conversation about.
Um,
so a,
do you agree that it was a sort of messy
interview a and B,
were you shocked?
Because I,
I would think everything being equal
that you would sit down with this guy
and he would absolutely love you.
You stand for every liberal value and
women's rights and equality and all
that.
And I thought it was really terrible.
It wasn't funny.
It definitely wasn't funny.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Isn't funny.
It wasn't funny.
And the reason why it wasn't funny,
it was probably because it was about
Islam and Islam is not funny at the
moment.
And I don't know what it goes.
I can't speculate on what the see what
somebody work,
but you know,
imagine if the next morning he gets a
threat,
he gets whatever,
you know,
people telling him that he hasn't
treated them fairly.
You can't laugh at Islam.
There's nothing funny.
I mean,
I can,
I can make a lot of comedy about the
absurdities of Islam and all the sad
things that are done in the name of
Islam,
but nowadays that comes laced with
threats laced with resentment.
So it wasn't a funny show.
Uh,
I don't,
um,
I mean in hindsight I asked myself why
he even agreed to it.
Uh,
but it,
it is for him.
He's,
he's an adult and he,
he will probably have his own
explanations in his own lesson.
Yeah.
Listen,
I,
I know that saying anything negative or
whatever about John is not going to win
me any Brownie points,
but I thought that because not only was
the tone of it unnecessarily combative
as opposed to just listening to you,
but then at the end he said something to
the effect as he was saying goodbye to
you,
like basically like,
ah,
you just want to sell some books.
And I really thought it was just
incredibly dismissive.
And of course you kept your calm and
your cool and all of that.
Well,
that's funny because people go to John
who had books,
just sell books and sell a bunch of
books,
but that is,
I mean,
I think what he did it to a certain
degree was put himself in the shoes of
my opponents and in doing so,
I think the people,
he entertained a thought that this is
not entertaining,
this is not funny.
Yeah.
Interesting.
All right.
I think that's the west view.
You can give comedia.
Yeah,
exactly.
All right.
So,
uh,
so I have one more for you,
that sort.
I want to try to tie this altogether.
So,
uh,
you know,
you alluded to security threats that,
that you still have,
you know,
your life story as we've said.
It's just,
it's just incredible and an inspiration.
I think,
um,
Gimme something to end this,
that we can all feel good about the
direction that this is going.
You know,
we've talked a little bit about how the
voices are finally raising up in the
liberal community against the
regressives and I think a lot of my
audience take solace in that.
Um,
but,
but give me something that you from
everything that you've lived through
that you can really help us all take
with us and feel good and feel like,
feel like we can,
we can win for the right reasons and the
right principles.
Well,
I mean the best news I have at the
moment is just the sheer number of
individuals who are born into Muslim
households who are rejecting the
absolute is submission narrative.
He was saying,
I think I don't like it if it comes to
choosing between my conscience and what
Mohammed tells me to do.
I go with my conscience and people are
paying with their lives.
I've talked about as much as I can,
a battery in Saudi Arabia of all.
Can you imagine living in Saudi Arabia
and somehow finding the intellectually,
the capacity to say no to all this and
stand up for a message of freedom and
rationality and reason and science and
then having to deal with the
consequences.
This man is sentenced to a thousand
lashes.
50 of them have been carried out,
is fighting for his life inside prison.
Now he is an icon,
but he's only one of what I now see as
thousands and I see them everywhere
because the emails I get,
I'm so heartened by that,
and 10 years ago it was the opposite.
Every single Muslim who called me,
he just called me an infidel and told
me,
you deserve to die,
and now people are saying,
oh my God,
you are.
You're my hero.
We're in this together.
And some of them still identify as
Muslim.
They're not necessarily out,
but they are.
They're thinking and you and me and all
the other liberals,
the one thing we can advance is the idea
of critical thinking.
Let's just give people whether they're
Muslim or not,
the ability,
I mean just enhance their ability to
think critically about these things.
Yeah,
I love that.
I mean,
I,
that's,
that's pretty much what I've tried to
now make my life about and it's clearly
what,
what you've done.
So really this has been truly a thrill
to spend a little time with you and I
hope,
I know you're not going to be in la
probably for a couple months,
but I hope we can do it in person next
time.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for having me and David and
good luck with this,
with this show and keep up the good
work.
Thank you.
Likewise.
Uh Alright.
Well you guys can buy ions book.
It's called heretic A.
Pretty much wherever books are sold.
Where do you want them to buy it though?
Do you have a place you want to send
them?
I don't know.
I mean it's by whatever you can find it.
Whatever's convenient for you.
I guess
a nice message at the end.
Alright,
great.
Well thank you so much diane.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for having me.